elon musk is not only the world's
richest man he's also the founder and
ceo of spacex and he's also the ceo of
tesla and both of those businesses
they're very capital intensive they use
a lot of different commodities to create
the products that they ultimately then
sell so it's not a surprise that someone
like elon musk would have his pulse on
the global economy trying to understand
inflation and commodity prices and so to
see him recently tweet the question what
are your thoughts about probable
inflation over the next few years
immediately people started to wonder
what is elon musk really trying to
figure out will he follow that tweet up
with another one where he said that
tesla and spacex are seeing significant
recent inflation pressures in raw
materials and logistics and then he
showed that he's not alone that plenty
of other people are watching commodity
prices soared to the highest level since
2008 and so then michael saylor one of
the biggest bitcoin proponents in the
world came in and he tweeted and said us
dollar consumer inflation will continue
near all-time highs and asset inflation
will run at double the rate of consumer
inflation weaker currencies will
collapse and the flight of capital from
cash debt and value stocks to scarce
property like bitcoin will intensify and
of course elon somebody who understands
the internet well said it is not
entirely unpredictable that you michael
would reach that conclusion and so then
elon followed up with exactly the answer
to everyone's question what the hell do
i do if there's high inflation and he
said that as a general principle for
those looking for advice from this
thread it is generally better to own
physical things like a home or stocking
companies you think make good products
then to hold dollars when inflation is
high but with that said elon musk the
world's richest man still owns and won't
sell his bitcoin ethereum or doge for
whatever that's worth and so this is
what ends up happening when you have
high inflation is that there's an
education gap the rich people understand
hold physical assets hold equity hold
investments that is going to go up it's
going to be a beneficiary of the
inflation the bottom 45 of americans
have no investable assets they don't
know this and they're just going to hold
cash they're the ones who are hurt the
most by the inflation make sure you get
educated make sure you hold investments
and not cash savers are losers and
investors are the real winners in this
type of environment hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time